[音楽]
今
me
ああああああ
voodoo
[音楽]
ni
me
[音楽]
[拍手]
あっ小さい頃から絵を描くことが好きでした今でも変わらず
絵を描くことが大好きです
好きという気持ちは何よりも買い難いエネルギーになっております
それは私が人として生きてきた役割であり
地名であると今は確信して描いております
私はこの山深い信州という土地で自然の力を感じ時に不思議な体験をさせて頂きながら
大人になりました
ここで受けた阿久さんの体験の中で
私が描くテーマを確固たるものとした
一つの経験があります
とあれはまだ私が小さかった子供の頃
よく道に迷うと
太さ君待つメートル先に山犬が現れてその後を
どこ所ことを追っていくと
不思議といつのまにか家に戻ることができるという体験がありました
それは中学3年の冬まで続き
最後に見たのは
う武器の日でした
大粒の雪に立ち往生している私の目の先に
大きな病なが現れ
ど何度も振り返りながら私を先導してくれました
その時にふと思い私はあの足元を見ました
そこには私の足跡しかなかったんです
そこで私は
あーと声を出してしまいました
すると山犬は大きな円を描いてずっと目の前から聞いてしまいましたまるでこう
ぐるーっと回ってずーっとぐるーっと回ってふっとほっ
いえてしまいましたってすぐに走ってその現場に入ったら
何も足跡がありませんでした
そんな不思議な体験をしてから私は
あの時に見た山犬を無意識のうちに探すようになりました
そこで訪れたのが私の地元である
酒気町にあります榊神社で
そこで参拝をさせて頂いた時に気付いたんです
榊神社の参道に鎮座している
あの文化財にもなっている古い狛犬がいるんですけれども
その狛犬からあの時不思議な体験をした
山犬の気配があったんです
そこから私はお前ぬといふものを
そして守護獣というものを描くようになりました
それからというもの私はお前ぬというものはどういったものなのか
歴史を調べるようになりました
細いのはもともとエジプトにあるスフィンクスやあの旧約聖書に出てくる
ケルビムといった守護獣にルーツがあり中国や韓国の市文化を経て海を渡り日本にやっ
てきて細い付となりました
また実際に足を運んで
イスラエルやインドタイ中国や韓国ヨーロッパや南米にも旅しながら各地に伝わる
守護獣8スピリット文化を自分で写真に収め
造形から見るスピリット文化を
の今日つピリッと文化から見る共通性を見つけました
その共通性というのは
すべての中に含まれている守護獣という
中強の壁を越えた
共通性がありました
そしてその46通行も自然と狛犬に達して描くようになりました
ともともと日本の真の文化もたくさんの文化がこの島国に集まり
その文化のエッセンスを抽出し混ぜたものであるのです
また私が今着ているまああの袴ですがあのにょきものですね
日本の着物もまた他国からの献上品からヒントを得た図柄が取り込まれています
あとは異文化をまとめデザインすることであるのです
狛犬も同じようにはという方法で
をとなる宗教が時代の流れ文化の波の中で混ざり合い
一つの形態となりました
そこから見えてくることはすべての審理は一つであり我々は一様にして同じ赤い血の
流れる
人間であるということです
そして話が4か月ほど前に戻るのですが今着ている衣装は先ほどの映像で観ていただい
た衣装で来ていたもので
a
私は改めて生まれ育ち
私に描くことの喜びをくださった信州そして坂城町に戻り
まだまた新たな進化を解くでを取りライブという形で地元のお祭りのイベントの中で
絵の具をキャンバスにぶつける機会をいただけました
題材はもちろん狛犬であります
そして不思議な体験をしたときに見た山犬様の姿を混ぜることでした
そこから新たに自分が原点を経て進化していくことを祈り会が貸していただけました
としかし実写 in 出来上がった作品は
私が最初に思ってたものと違うものでした
当時見た山犬と狛犬ではなかったのです
ここに今あるのがその時の作品なんですけれども私は改めて絵の具が乾いた頃合いに
この作品と向き合い
会話することで自分でも今まで気づかなかった事柄に火がつかしていただきました
それはこの絵には私がこれまで歩いて集めた沢山の国々に住まう
神獣たちの面影があるということでした
今までに経験した文化が知らぬ間に私の脳が吸収しまたひとつの形となって無意識の中
で現れていたのです
それこそが私の愛人ティティである和の心であり
しかしはとは方法であって
その方法が海を越えて地球に作用することで大きな輪になり
ヤマトとなるのだと改めて思い知らされたんです
そのヤマトをなる片鱗を自分の絵が最初から求めていたことに
信州坂城町地元に帰って
を改めて気づかせていただきました
そして
私はその気づきそして魂の成長とともに
これからも死ぬまで
神獣スピリット
原点である狛犬も描いていくでしょう
それらはすべてかけがえのない地球文化の1つでありそのどれもが重要で貴重であり
どれもがみな共通点を持っているなと
まだ若輩者であるが気づかせていただいたすべての学びに感謝を込めて
そして全てに尊敬という心を忘れないで強く思い
強く幅大抵今後も描き続けていきます
ありがとうございました
[拍手]